blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com pakman all
right welcome everybody i want to start
today
with something different we're not going
to look at media pieces right now we're
going to look at
some interesting op-eds that have been
written um in the last 24 to 48 hours
they relate to one is in the new york
times one's in the washington post they
relate to
pretty big issues facing us right now
and questions about
the economy and democracy and upcoming
elections and so on so let me know if
this is
interesting to you and maybe we will do
more of this
i want to start with an article in the
new york times
called americans don't want to return
to low-wage jobs this was written
yesterday it's an opinion piece
by daniel alpert who's a senior fellow
in macroeconomics and finance at cornell
and it's specifically about this issue
where the right is framing it as
businesses
can't find people to hire because people
are making too much money off of this
enhanced unemployment
so people would rather stay home and
make more or the same
or close to the same rather than go in
and get some job and that is not
the way i would characterize the
situation and i think this article does
a lot of interesting
uh uh a good job of pointing out a lot
of the aspects of this so
let's skim through it daniel writes the
hope for
hopes for a booming pandemic recovery
growth led by job gains
in the millions every month were dealt a
blow in recent weeks
by a disappointing april jobs report
perhaps we'll see better when results
for mayor released this week on friday
but for weeks many democratic policy and
political circles have been queasy
about addressing the connection between
federally supplemented unemployment
insurance benefits
and the slowing pace of reemployment at
this stage of the recovery from the
pandemic
there is almost certainly a common sense
connection if you were a low-wage worker
why aggressively attempt to go back to
work at a lousy low-paying job
when you can make more money by
collecting unemployment benefits
still republican politicians are getting
it wrong too
they are citing countless news reports
that businesses are struggling to fill
certain positions
as both a reason to end federal
unemployment benefits
and as evidence that the extra benefits
were too generous in the first place
they worry that the ability of some
workers to stay on the sidelines of the
label
labor market unless employers offer
wages that
trump jobless benefits could result in
dangerous wage inflation
a potential increase in labor costs that
they believe
consumers will pay for in the form of
higher priced goods and services
this is the key part that argument
simply does not hold water either
over the coming weeks and months as this
aid for the jobless phases out
there will be a flood of anxious job
seekers pouring into labor markets even
if a significant share of workers are
temporarily avoiding
taking low paying jobs while benefits
remain generous
then there is no true labor shortage as
many
economists and market commentators are
calling it
this is essentially the argument i've
been making for some time
which is the enhanced unemployment was
one of the best
parts of what was done by both
the trump administration and the biden
administration remember two stimulus
packages under trump for covid one under
joe biden
with any welfare system or with just
about any wealth
welfare system there will be some
people that are better off on the
welfare
than getting out of the situation in
which they qualify for the welfare
that's always a thing
and in this case because of these
enhanced unemployment benefits
and the fact that different states have
different baseline benefits to begin
with
it's conceivable that some people made
more by not working than by working that
we're not denying that the point is
overall at the macroeconomic level the
enhanced unemployment
saved so many people in so many families
for
for millions and millions of people and
it's ending
and it's ending now the other side of
this which we will get into here
is that there's the uh uh left-wing
argument
which counters the right-wing argument
that was just outlined
that if people don't want to go and work
for you
then your wages are too low i mean the
way that a market works
is if you don't like the supply of labor
available to you if you're offering
eight bucks an hour
then maybe you offer 10 bucks an hour
and that gets more people
interested now the counter would be it's
being
the the the we have an artificially
inter
inserted problem here it's not that the
market has dictated
8 or 10 or 12 or whatever the minimum
wage is in some places is too low
it's that there's this government coming
in on top and dropping this enhanced
unemployment
and that's distorting the market well
it's going to end
right if that's your argument that's
that's soon to end
um daniel alpert writes enhanced
benefits are ending every day for the
millions of americans who have benefited
from the pandemic emergency unemployment
compensation program
which extends unemployment insurance for
13 weeks to those who exhausted their
conventional
state and federal unemployment benefits
all extra federal supplements
will end on september 6th including the
general 300
weekly benefit and the pandemic
unemployment assistance
which provides aid to those who are
self-employed uh
going on to say in the aggregate during
the week that ended on may 1st
the unemployed were still receiving
almost 10 billion dollars in federal
transfers per week
that's money being directly injected
into local economies shutting off that
pipeline
means the economy at large could
experience one of two adverse outcomes
either there won't be enough jobs for
the people eventually looking for work
because so many businesses closed or the
jobs left will be
frankly lousier jobs the latter
possibility would leave a large share of
americans
underemployed which would cause a wide
reduction in household income among the
country's less wealthy half
this is a key point once unemployment
ends
and a lot of these folks who according
to the right
have just been hanging out on
unemployment making more than they would
at some of the jobs that are available
many of them are going to become
job seekers many of them are going to
become willing to accept some of these
crappy or lousy jobs this will i guess
satisfy some on the right that these
lazy people have finally gotten off
their you know what and gotten a job
macroeconomically it's not going to be
good when these folks
accept these subpar jobs if you adopt
a a spending is stimulus mindset a
demand side mindset
if joe whatever right if if some person
uh who was making i'm just picking
numbers
550 a week between state and enhanced
federal unemployment
has no choice because the unemployment
benefits end to accept a job making half
of that
they now only have half the money to
spend in their community
do you think that's going to be good for
all of the small businesses in that
community that joe
goes from having 550 to spend to only
having 275 dollars to spend no
that's a massive that's the problem that
happened when the pandemic hit
it was a massive reduction in demand
and that is what caused a lot of
business closures and the need for a lot
of this stuff
in the first place so uh daniel alpert
wraps by saying
um the majority of the jobs that aren't
back to
pre-pandemic workforce levels are very
low-income jobs
they are what the us private sector job
quality index which i co-created calls
low quality jobs
through march of this year most of the
private sector jobs eliminated during
the pandemic that haven't been restored
are production
and non-supervisory jobs that offer
weekly pay averaging less than 750
dollars pre-pandemic
there are more than 45 million
low-paying jobs like these constituting
roughly 43
of all production and non-supervisory
jobs in the country
this is not a mere unfortunate corner of
the jobs market that's a huge piece of
it
um and then the the big picture
that he points out here is the chronic
problem we face as we put kovid 19
in the rear view mirror is that the u.s
economy before the pandemic was
incredibly dependent on an abundance of
low wage low hours
jobs it was a combo that yielded low
prices for comfortably middle class and
wealthier customers
and low labor costs for bosses but
spectacularly low incomes
for tens of millions of others this
dynamic was first brought into stark
relief by the discourse about essential
workers
during the worst of the pandemic now it
will be highlighted by the frustrating
unequal outcomes of this great reopening
so it's not as simple as these jobs
should just
pay more and then everybody's going to
want them
people are going to want these jobs when
unemployment runs out
the problem is that it's not good for
the economy
at the macro level to have so many
people that are in such a precarious
situation while i think it maybe goes
too far
to simply say if people don't want to
come and work
for you as many restaurants for example
are complaining then your wages are too
low
in many cases the wages are too low
that's absolutely true
but there's a bigger economic reality
here which is
if just a couple hundred bucks in
unemployment benefits
makes working not worth it for so many
people which is what the right claims
that means that a huge portion of those
who are employed were
now we're not talking about in a
pandemic the folks that are saying
i make a little more or the same by not
working not in a pandemic
when you have even a low unemployment
rate
a lot of people are a hundred dollars a
week from
it not being worth it to go in that's
terrible for the economy that means that
so much of the spending that the economy
depends on
is hanging by a thread and this is the
point many progressive economists would
make so
the takeaway is not as simple as
unemployment benefits were too high and
so everybody was staying home now
it's not that simple it's not as simple
as well
this simply means all of these
businesses should raise
wages some of them should depends on the
state that we're talking about the point
is we have an economy that is so
precarious
so precarious that just a hundred or two
hundred dollars a week
makes all the difference in one being
able to afford their meager lifestyle
and in it no longer being worth it
to go in and actually work these jobs
that's really the issue here
let's talk next about an op-ed in the uh
washington post by max boot now i want
to give a disclaimer max boot
max boot is seeing seen as just a
horrible neo-liberal
terrible person by many people uh other
people like max boot
i don't really care what you think about
max boot max boot has written a very
interesting piece in the washington post
called
the republican plot to steal the 2024
election and he
outlines many of the ways that the 2024
election could go
saying republicans have spent nearly
seven months making bogus charges of
fraud
in the 2020 election under the banner of
stop the steel
now they've segued into a start the
steel offensive
to ensure that they will win the 2022
and 2024 elections
even if most voters once again support
the democratic party this is important
they're still talking about 2020 but
they're actually planning for 2022
and 2024. the brennan center for justice
reports that between january 1 and may
14
at least 14 states enacted 22 new laws
that's not even what's proposed right
look proposals are in the hundreds
that restrict access to the vote and at
least 61 bills with restrictive
provisions are moving through 18 state
legislatures these bills are designed
not to avert non-existent voter fraud
but to avert another election defeat for
republicans and they are drawing
perilously close to that goal max points
out
some of the specific cases in georgia
which we've discussed
in texas and in other places but what i
think is most important here is the big
picture analysis
where max boot writes while republican
efforts are ultimately aimed at the 2024
election they will first make their
impact felt in 2022 off-year elections
are always tough for the party in power
this one will be tougher still because
of republican driven
voter suppression reapportionment and
gerrymandering
dave wasserman of the cook political
report writes that republicans will have
full authority to redraw 187
congressional districts
while democrats will control just 75.
the gerrymandering will get worse
he estimates that redistricting in just
four states texas florida georgia and
north carolina
could be enough to deliver the house to
republican control
this brings us to a nightmare scenario a
republican-controlled congress
overturning the 2024 presidential
election
results to install trump or a trump
mini-me in the white house
in january 139 house republicans and
eight senate republicans voted not to
certify
the electoral college results in at
least one state since then
the most prominent republican opponent
of the big lie congresswoman liz cheney
has been purged from the house
leadership
willingness to lie about election fraud
has become a litmus test for republicans
with the implicit threat of mob violence
if they don't go along republicans are
so
scared of trump and his fanatical
followers that most of them just voted
against the bipartisan investigation of
the january
6th attack on the capital if you think
that they aren't going to try even
harder
in 2022 and 2024 just you wait
they have given up policy the republic
what policy is the republican party for
right now
they've abandoned policy it's obstruct
democrats
and try to win by legislating who can
vote
and how easy it is for certain people to
vote they are going to do what they did
in 2020
times 10 in 2022 end times 20
in 2024 um max boot goes on to say
many congressional republicans will
refuse to certify
a 2024 democratic win in swing states if
republicans control congress
they could deny the democrats an
electoral college majority
and throw the election to the house
where each state delegation regardless
of population would cast one ballot
given that republicans already control a
majority of state delegations
they could override the election outcome
if that happens
it would spell the end of american
democracy now if you don't think
republicans would do this
come on guys they january 6th
look at january 6th look at even now
later in the show
donald trump is now saying he thinks he
might be reinstated in august
uh multiple republicans and right-wing
media figures michael flynn tucker
carlson matt gates are talking about
let's use guns to get what we need
let's do a real insurrection let's do a
cool like acou like in myanmar or
minamar as michael flynn's uh audience
member said
um if you don't think they're willing to
do this what will stop them from doing
this
is if they're unable to but they are
going to try
and uh the the specifics of
can they really do it this way can they
really do it that way could the house
alone pull this off don't they need the
senate as well
yeah we're going to look at all of those
scenarios
but they have too many options as the
problem if
they could look at putting in trumpsters
trumpeters whatever you call them
as secretaries of states in the midwest
um
still not easy in 2022 but maybe for
2024
and so this is something they are going
to do
2016 was a warm-up to what they tried in
2020.
fortunately in 2020 joe biden just had
enough turnout that he ended up winning
2022 is going to be nuts and 2024
even more if republicans succeed
in 2022 either in the house senate
or at the state level so there is a lot
to be afraid of
and whatever you think about max boot on
this i don't think he's being too
alarmist i think he's exactly right
let me know your thoughts you can find
me on twitter at d
pacman follow me there and we'll be
right back
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
non-fiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy
science they have 27 different
non-fiction categories and a
subscription is
only about eight bucks a month and you
get the entire
library but you can try it totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
the david pakman show is made possible
primarily by people who sign up for
memberships at joinpacman.com if you
miss the monday memorial day membership
discount
fear not you can take advantage of it
through the end of the week the coupon
code is
memorial21 it'll work uh to discount any
membership
at joinpakman.com we are really
now for the first time seeing the rapid
decline of coronavirus cases in some
states it's down to almost a statistical
zero
it's not literally zero cases but it's
statistically low enough
where there's really no spread most
people who are getting sick are not
passing it to anyone
and that's how you reduce the number of
cases this is just a good
thing let's look at the latest numbers
starting with us cases
nationally which have declined now
more than 93 from their peak
the peak was 255 000 cases per day in
late january
now down or early january now down below
18
000 cases per day we are really getting
there
the deaths are fortunately starting to
come down with them
deaths are now down about 87 percent
from their peak
below 500 a day from the for the first
time
since march of 2020 deaths are at their
lowest in
about 15 months now is there anywhere in
the u.s where cases are going up
not really there are places where they
sort of aren't going down anymore
and they tend to be places with low
rates of vaccination so
mississippi is an example where cases
have been level for about 10 weeks
they're not growing
but they're not really shrinking anymore
that's not great
they need to vaccinate but lots of
people there don't want the vaccine
it's likely that eventually the places
with lower vaccination rates are going
to just see continued clusters
while the highly vaccinated states are
going to go down to again statistically
zero not
literally zero but almost in terms of
globally
in south america things are not good and
i was just looking at what's going on in
my
birth country of argentina and it's a
disaster
but overall it's not just american cases
and deaths that are coming down
global cases are now declining pretty
rapidly from their peak at one point
globe we had 830
000 new global cases per day that's now
down about 40 percent
to 485 000 cases per day down
almost half and then global deaths are
also
more slowly declining but down
about 25 percent from their peak at one
point
14 000 humans per day were dying
from kovid we still have about 11 000
dying per day
of this virus uh overwhelmingly it's
happening in the least
vaccinated countries re restating
underlining the importance of getting
vaccines to
all parts of the world this is not over
but in some places
it will effectively be over soon more
mass mandates are being pulled
in states were pulled over memorial day
weekend
the vaccines work well against the
variants so
it's not time to go crazy and do stupid
stuff i think at this point we all know
what is what is considered stupid at
this point in time large gatherings of
unvaccinated people indoors
is basically the stupidest thing you can
do but vaccinated people can do
most things with what we would call
baseline risk
and this is a really important concept
to understand because
psychologically the pandemic has really
shaken up
our concept of the risks we accept by
existing in the world
risk wasn't zero before this pandemic
you could go out and you could get a
cold you could go out and you could get
the flu and sometimes people die of the
flu you could go out and pick up a
stomach bug through
physical contact or in a restaurant or
whatever you could get in a car accident
so the question for me is not when is
the risk of covet zero
but it's when is it low enough that we
would consider when i go out
i'm at baseline risk meaning i'm
accepting that
generally there's some risk to being in
the world but there's not this acute
thing
and vaccines are a huge part of getting
back to that baseline
level of risk of just being alive and
existing in the world even staying home
you could fall down the stairs i get it
even staying staying home you could
poison yourself with lead pain i don't
know
but but the point here is there are lots
of people
who before this pandemic were accepting
risks by being out in the world that
maybe they didn't even
quantify and i think that now because
we're so aware of it
it's going to feel scarier and like i
get it i was uh
you know i the other day at the grocery
store um
there just before uh more mass
guidelines were pulled there were
already a bunch of people without masks
i was wearing my mask because that was
the rules at the time and i see the
people without the mask and it's like
whoa whoa it's
like you visualize a stream of germs
coming out of their mouth
we accepted that before right for my 30
whatever years that i lived until the
pandemic
i accepted that and didn't think twice
about it the question is when will we be
back to that
and then is that an acceptable level of
risk for some people going back to the
old level of risk for example a flu
won't be acceptable and people are going
to continue wearing a mask
and that's fine but it's going back to
normal but it's sort of a new normal
where i think all of us are more aware
of the risk to just being out in the
world now one last thing
vaccination keeps slowing down in the
u.s
even though there are tons more people
to vaccinate daily vaccine doses are
down to 1.5 million a day
at one point they were at more than
double that 3.3 million a day
there are tons of people still to
vaccinate
if they don't get vaccinated some are
going to get covered
and some are going to die and many
doctors believe that
because this is going to keep
circulating if you're not vaccinated
that it's almost certain at some point
you will get it
um something to think about and that
let's now talk a little more
about the psychological impact of this
pandemic i got a really great email
from a viewer named wade who said kovid
has taken away our ability to behave
and i think it goes much further there
seems to be almost like a covid induced
psychosis that is plaguing
this country and some other parts of the
world and i want to go through it today
i already discussed on yesterday's bonus
show that a number of
unruly passengers on airplanes are being
reported to the faa
that number is increasing dramatically
and much of it is related to or it's
triggered by masks
people angry about someone else wearing
a mask people angry about someone else
not wearing a mask masks and just
getting back to being in close quarters
with people on airplanes
is causing many unruly passengers we
talked about that yesterday
but as wade wrote to me he said quote as
more and more people attend events and
begin to travel
there's an increasing level of violence
and frustration that on the surface
might seem to result
of not having to practice decorum and
civility
in similar situations for the past year
due to the pandemic
i think there's something to this one
category
fan behavior at sporting events in
washington dc
fans fan runs onto court during
washington wizards game four
in latest act of misbehavior games just
started and there's a rash of this the
76ers
knicks and jazz have had to ban
fans following playoff game incidents
involving players
then it grew more and now five nba
venues
have banned fans for disrespectful
behavior during games
and it's not just happening in
basketball and it's not just happening
in the u.s
in glasgow scotland fans of the rangers
football club went nuts
thousands of them defying coveted
warnings against large gatherings
getting together in george square to
celebrate the rangers winning their
first
scottish premiership championship in 10
years
the square was just strewn with broken
bottles and bags and
there were flares launched and all sorts
of stuff
riot police came out and then lastly on
the sports front
maskless razorbacks fans in
arkansas led to
a bunch of arrests and charges one such
fan pleaded guilty
to violating the face coverings rule
then we have all of the airline stuff
a report from cnbc explaining that a
flight attendant union chief
says unruly behavior from plane
passengers has never been this bad
we mentioned yesterday that a southwest
airlines passenger punched out a flight
attendant's teeth last week
i believe two teeth it's actually so bad
that american airlines is extending
their suspension of alcohol service
because they believe the alcohol
can be an aggravating factor yeah it can
and then the road rage has just exploded
some examples include
a rash of road rage incidents in north
carolina in los
angeles in colorado in atlanta i don't
believe
this is as simple as people have gotten
used to not having to behave
because they've been home for a year
plus and now they're around people and
they forgot how to behave
that just doesn't strike me as the
explanation some of this
is that there are people who just no
longer care about decorum
some are furious about the pandemic and
about shutdowns
and instead of just being glad to be
back to doing things they're going nuts
and they're taking their fury out on
others
for other people there's just the
difficulty of reintegrating after being
as many people were and continue to be
so scared to do anything
and there's a sort of ptsd taking place
it's coming out
in some weird ways for other people i
think
the becoming unaccustomed to being in
groups
has created a sort of agoraphobia and
some people
stay home as a result of it others just
kind of
feel stressed when they go out and then
you have people who are reacting by
lashing out in some of these weird ways
i think this is going to continue for
some time
we've not even we're only starting to
see the resumption and travel
we're seeing oh but let me mention one
other thing
um commuting is horrible psychologically
people who have long commutes it's just
a real
drag on quality of life we know this
from study after study
not having to commute for so long for
many people
and then being dropped back into a
commute as traffic is starting to build
again
um i can only imagine that that's having
a real impact on a lot of people's
psychological state it took months to
adjust
to what was a new reality during the
pandemic
i think it's going to take at least a
few months to adjust
to getting out of it if indeed we
continue to get out of it and hopefully
we will as vaccination continue but i
don't think that there's
any easy solution to this let me know
what you think
and we'll have more on this on our
instagram
where you can find us at david pakman
show
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way
is through membership which includes the
world famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio
and video streams of the show just for
members
sign up today at joinpakman.com
coupon code saves you 40 better 21.
we have some good but potentially
temporary
news depending on who the next president
is and that
news is that president joe biden has
suspended drilling leases
in the arctic national wildlife refuge
also known as
anwar the decision blocks for now oil
and gas drilling in one of the largest
tracts of undeveloped
wilderness in the united states the
biden administration yesterday suspended
oil drilling leases in anwar unspooling
a signature achievement of the trump
presidency that's a good thing
and delivering on a promise by president
biden to protect the fragile alaskan
tundra
from fossil fuel extraction the decision
sets up a process that could halt
drilling in one of the largest tracts of
untouched wilderness in the u.s
home to migrating waterfowl caribou and
polar bears
but it also lies over as much as 11
billion barrels of oil
and democrats and republicans have
fought over whether to allow drilling
there for more than four decades
a former formal order from secretary
interior secretary deb halland paused
the leases
until her agency has completed an
environmental analysis of their impact
and a legal review of the trump
administration's decision
to grant them so this is good
this is this is what could be done right
now we're four months in or
yeah four months in almost five four and
a half months into joe biden's
presidency
but this really needs to be made
permanent and and
the point that i keep going back to on
this is we really don't need this
and of course you know the right wingers
the gas
price will go up a tenth of a cent again
and they'll point to this i actually saw
uh
a comment on reddit which said nothing
like
importing foreign oil at increased rates
just so that later we can go and drill
the very oil
that we are now protecting no one is
thinking long term
that is such a an incorrect
perspective the whole point here is
we should be moving away from oil
anybody who's saying
you know the goal for energy should be
let's keep pushing even if it takes
years
to be drilling in the arctic in the
anwar
refuge no no no no we we should be using
this time during which we actually
already have plenty of oil
to transition away from oil and i think
that
very often this debate gets into these
straw man arguments like
listen if you shut off oil today heat
indoor heating goes away we don't have
gasoline for vehicles we don't have this
we don't have that
i don't know who they're referring to
when they say that
but i've never met anyone serious on the
left who says we should be off oil today
i understand that if we there would be
no way to get off of oil today
but the whole point here is we should be
dramatically accelerating
solar power development oh but david
there's not a you can't use solar power
to generate
well look at the efficiency increase
we've seen in solar panels over the last
20 years
and if we get even half of the same over
the next 10
that goes a huge way in combination with
wind
and geothermal etc now there is a real
conversation to have about nuclear
i've said before new nuclear
is very very safe i am not
a reflexive anti-nuclear activist
very often and we've talked to nuclear
uh engineers on the nuclear
energy engineers on the show very often
there's this reflexive oh but look at
look at chernobyl and look at this stuff
from
from the 70s uh the reality is
that if we were to bring on new nuclear
today
with modern nuclear technology none of
those things would be
issues so for me i'm totally comfortable
using new nuclear as a stop gap what are
the concerns that i have with it number
one
the disposal of the waste continues to
be an issue
um i don't know about you know but
there's people who say now you just ship
it you put it underground it's fine
i'm just not sure about that i'm not
saying there isn't a solution but that
still remains a question for me but
really the bigger question for me with
saying
let's use nuclear as a way to be a
bridge
off of fossil fuels and onto alt real
renewables
is that it seems to me we would get
addicted to nuclear
and it takes a while to bring new
nuclear technology online so
my concern would be if we say let's do
new nuclear
and it'll take eight years to bring some
of this online
by the time that it's online the fact
that we've been focusing on nuclear
might have diverted energy and attention
and funding
from get from real renewables and that
scares me but
in theory i am not against doing uh new
safe nuclear as a stop gap um
one other thing there are people who who
like to say
the sun's not really renewable you know
i mean
we've got five to six billion years of
solar okay that's
if we by fi if the human race survives
that long
we can never be certain about anything
but i would be reasonably sure
that we would have moved somewhere where
the sun exploding in five to six billion
years
is not going to be uh what destroys the
human race so for all practical purposes
when we're talking about
peak oil and we're talking about 10 20
50 100 year timelines of what we're
doing to the planet with oil use
five to six billion years of solar power
sounds pretty damn renewable to me all
right so good decision by joe biden
uh will follow it and of course there's
a bigger conversation here
about a bigger transition that needs to
take place if you thought that the idol
chatter about aku
like in myanmar and trump posting to his
blog about
audits were happening in a vacuum you
were very much wrong the new york times
maggie haberman is now reporting that
donald trump is telling people privately
he will be reinstated as president of
the united states by august of this year
this is actually something that more and
more q anon people are attaching to now
now the context here
is that on sunday night trump's former
national security adviser
michael flynn remember the guy who was
indicted and convicted and then pardoned
by trump
he said to an audience that there should
be a
coup here like the one that took place
in myanmar
that's outrageous enough but this
appears to be part of
i hesitate to call it a political
movement but it's part of
something that trump is again ginning up
which again might lead to real violence
so here's the latest from the new york
times's maggie haberman who tweeted
yesterday that quote
trump has been telling a number of
people he's in contact with that he
expects
he will get reinstated by august no that
isn't how it works but simply sharing
the information
now the concept of reinstated is
hilarious when
you know the process for presidents
becoming president is being
elected reinstated is not a term that
applies to the presidency it's you're
elected and then you're inaugurated and
then you surf
who would reinstate him is the idea of
the supreme court how would that work it
doesn't make any sense
maggie haberman goes on to say quote it
isn't happening in a vacuum
it is happening as he faced the
possibility of an indictment from the
manhattan district attorney
and then lastly adding that quote he is
not putting out statements about the
audits and states just for the sake of
it
he's been laser focused on them
according to several people who've
spoken with him
as well as washington post reporting a
few weeks ago
now whether donald trump thinks he'll be
back by coup
or by some other means isn't clear but
the entire myanmar-style coup
thing to take joe biden out of the white
house
has been floating around q and on
circles for months
and here's an interview done by cnn with
such people
i guess we would call them who have the
same idea biden is just
he's like a puppet president uh the
military is in charge it's going to be
like myanmar what's happening in myanmar
the military is doing their own
investigation and at the right time
they're going to be restoring the
republic with trump as president
in different countries the government
took over and they're rejoining the
election correct
that could possibly happen here possibly
would you like to see it happen
absolutely i would like to see it really
yes you know why
because the election was stolen from us
i would take any bet
that this is the first time most of
these people have even heard of myanmar
i mean seriously and and certainly the
first time they've ever pretended to
care about it
so of course none of it will happen but
in the process of not happening
if it just gets enough oxygen it might
inspire more violence
it's easy to laugh and to say ignore
this crab
forget it or whatever but these are
dangerous delusions
they are delusions but after the january
6 trump riots we can't say they are
merely delusions they are
dangerously deluded now some are already
saying
put two and two together david michael
flynn says there should be a coup
trump is thinking about august trump is
planning a violent coup
we can't say that yet i wouldn't put it
past trump to try it
uh and it wouldn't work but we really
shouldn't say that he is planning a
violent coup because we don't know that
and that would be irresponsible
would he be morally opposed to it no
probably not
are we to expect new arbitrary
announcements about august september
what up for the next few years
probably this helps with fundraising i'm
sure
many of them probably don't realize it's
never going to happen and once august
comes and goes
it'll be january and then it'll be
listen the way to take this back
is actually to vote republicans in
in november of 2022 so that they take
control back of congress then we can
impeach
biden and replace him with donald trump
it'll just keep going and going and
going it's the never ending grift
but this is my last thought and this is
important
if this is true that donald trump is
seriously telling people i'll be
reinstated as president by august
it's a grift but it's not just a grift
it's working to grift money from people
but if trump really believes it himself
that's scarier
than trump merely being a con man he is
a con man
but then he also seems as deluded
himself
as are many of his followers and to me
that's even scarier
let me know what you think let me know
what percentage
of trump's followers really believe
trump could be reinstated by august and
how many understand that that's just
never ever ever going to happen we'll
take a quick break
and be right back after this
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners and
one way to keep us going is through
patreon
where you can pledge as little as one
dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
slash david pakman show great perks and
benefits as well
read about them so to some degree things
are not going particularly well for the
trump family right now i mean they're
still rich or and they're still
privileged and they're still powerful
but
there are criminal investigations going
on into their businesses
trump's social media reach has been
replaced by a blog
that nobody reads etc and now
eric trump and donald trump jr two of
donald trump's kids
are doing a sort of pity me pity us
media tour and it's just hilarious and
pathetic
i don't know that i've ever seen a
family that is so privileged
constantly claimed to be the biggest
victims
of everything and everyone and i think
it all comes down from trump trump
regularly claiming i've nobody's been
treated as unfairly as me and
so check out some of these clips here is
eric trump last night
on sean hannity's fox news propaganda
show and in this clip
eric trump whines we just get all these
subpoenas and they're treating us so
terribly and then he just starts
telling lies see if you can pick up on
the lies and i know that his mouth
moving is a signal that he's lying but
there's a specific lie that he tells
here investigating his zero experienced
son being paid millions
and all of these other instances now
where he's been caught
red-handed lying about knowing anything
about hunter's foreign business dealings
sean i agree completely listen i'm on
the receiving end of every single day my
father gets subpoena after subpoena we
do as a family
they attack us they go after us for
doing absolutely nothing wrong we gave
up business when my father went to the
white house
they did the exact opposite when joe
biden became vice president hunter
biden got into business but yet every
single day my family is attacked
and they look for any comma that's out
of place and the prosecutorial
misconduct in this country is out of
control
but yet because we're republicans they
attack us and they do absolutely nothing
to the other side
yeah so pity me pity us but he says we
gave up
our business when trump became president
no you didn't
donald trump made 1.6 billion dollars
during his four years as president from
his private businesses
ivanka and jared kushner
made hundreds of millions i believe it
was 640 million
if i recall correctly from the family
business what are you talking about
they literally opened the trump dc hotel
blocks from the white house
while trump was running for president in
2016 and then as soon as trump was
inaugurated
foreign leaders would come to trump's dc
hotel and stay there
when they would go visit trump or visit
uh other diplomats or american officials
in order to ingratiate themselves with
the trump white house
what kind of fantasy world is this guy
living in that not only
he portrays himself as a huge victim he
also just tells lies about the things
that they've done and not done
then last night it wasn't just eric
trump with sean hannity
it was also donald trump jr with um
tucker carlson on fox news and in this
clip don jr says hey
the fact that my dad is being
investigated
this is what you expect in so-called
banana republics not
in the united states more but if this
was going on in the banana republic we'd
be outraged
when it's going on in one of the largest
states in america
everyone seems to be silent on it and so
there's two things here first of all is
it not possible for don jr
to make a political point without using
a pejorative term about other countries
like i
i'm not saying banana republic is like
the n-word banana republic
it describes a country that's less
developed with political instability
often an economy that depends on
exporting
one thing like a banana or a particular
mineral a con a rare earth mineral a
conflict mineral whatever the case may
be so
it's not the n-word it's not calling a
jewish person the k
word don't get me wrong but it's a
pejorative it's a derogatory term
and you know he just can't seem to make
any
statement without kind of using a gross
term about someone or some other country
but the funny thing about the
comparisons to developing nations
is that the the real analogy between
trump
and developing nations is the one we
made during the trump era which is
trump's authoritarianism trump's disdain
for freedom of the press
trump's comfort with cronyism and
nepotism
and corruption and slush funds and all
of this stuff
that's what we are used to seeing
in the corrupt countries of the
developing world
often run by authoritarians or even
authoritarian more developed nations you
get the picture so
there is they they seem to stumble
across
the fact that there are things happening
here
that have an analogy in other parts of
the world
but they just get the analogy completely
wrong it's not the investigation of
trump
that makes us like a so-called banana
republic it was trump
as an authoritarian buffoon as president
that made us
like all of these other countries whose
leaders trump admired by the way people
like duterte
and kim jong-un and putin and the others
in any case eric and don jr
making the rounds claiming to be victims
and
if anybody gets charged in these probes
i mean listen if the manhattan d.a
charges somebody trump or other trump
associates
if the new york ag probe leads to
charges
we have so much of this insanity to look
forward to if there are any charges
brought
in those investigations it will be these
two don jr and eric
completely unmoored from reality
claiming everybody's just being so mean
and unfair and everything's just a
a scam endeavor a witch hunt they stole
everything they could while in the white
house
they stripped the country down to the
studs and now they're saying we did
everything right
and they won't leave daddy alone in some
sense
they're not used to facing consequences
so it probably is very confusing because
of the attention
that trump brought on himself by running
for president and becoming president
the charity was investigated and
ultimately had to pay a fine and be shut
down
now there are multiple investigations
they just don't like their actions
having consequences for
a long time trump wasn't sconced up in
trump tower in his office or penthouse
or whatever
and people were paying attention to him
but not like they started to when he ran
for president
and uh even losing the presidency
after having arguably the most
disastrous presidential term in modern
political history
that's a consequence and they're simply
not used to that
they're used to being the bullies and
there may now actually be some
consequences
okay so we've been i don't want to spend
a lot of time on this but this this
is uh important it's newsworthy um we've
been
talking about what is 2022 going to look
like to what degree
will the republican party lean towards
trumpism in 2022
or against from trumpism in 2022 if you
look at the polling so far
trump's popular with most republican
voters um
the republican electorate seems to have
no real desire for
policy being a thing that plays a
prominent role
in republican politics going into 2022
so trump plans to play king maker
and he may well get away with it and the
news now is that donald trump is again
going back to rallies
upcoming trump rallies max burns says
that the upcoming trump rallies
will help democrats remind voters why
they didn't
reelect him that's a very optimistic
perspective on these rallies
max burns writes this summer doesn't
mark
only the return of family get-togethers
and concerts
starting this month donald trump will
also be back in public circulation
headlining a series of grievance-filled
summer maga rallies and max says that
that's great news for anxious democrats
the return of trump's hours-long
rambling rallies is an opportunity to
remind the american people that
republican craziness hasn't dialed down
a notch
since his defeat last year and to remind
democrats
that they have reason to focus on their
shared values
rather than their increasingly bitter
senate fights
max burns goes on to say by now most
americans know
to expect plenty of disinformation and
far-right red meat from trump rallies
but they have yet to see how a
humiliating
electoral loss and trump's delusional
claim that he's about to be reinstated
as president any day now
mix with tried and true trump classics
like spreading election disinformation
and whining about cancel culture
after just one trump rally democrats
will have plenty of sound bites and
offensive content to make the case
that trump has learned nothing during
his time out of office surrounded by yes
men at mar-a-lago
and while trump's unhinged claims to be
the president of the united states in
exile
may energize mega fundamentalists they
reaffirm to independents and moderates
who rejected trump
that he has if anything grown more
detached from reality
in defeat i don't know that i'm as
optimistic as max burns
because what you have to remember is
that turnout
in general is down in midterms and so i
would expect
that neither democrats nor republicans
would see the turnout that they saw
in the 2020 presidential election if
democrats see unhinged trump rallies
maybe some of them who wouldn't
ordinarily vote in a midterm
might get out and vote but it's really
the republicans
who have been so deflated by this loss
who stand to gain from seeing trump
continuing to keep going
flying around the country supporting
marjorie taylor greene
supporting this person that person
whoever the case may be so for me it's
not as clear i mean yeah
trump will do the rallies and they'll be
insane and they'll be unhinged and
they'll be depraved and he'll tell
corrosive lies about american democracy
for sure
but it seems to me that there is much
more for republicans to gain
than what there is for democrats to gain
from it and there's one other thing and
i think this this is just a real fear
that i have and i know many in the
audience share it because they email me
about it um i think that the
impact of these rallies that trump will
start reportedly as soon as this month
may well incite trump's supporters
to be predisposed to more violence to
another insurrection attempt
to widespread violence against you know
whoever they perceive to be their enemy
on the left
and if you combine trump rallies in june
and july with trump reportedly starting
to say he will be reinstated as
president in august
and then when that doesn't happen i'm
worried about another january 6th and i
know that
there's it's becoming very um what's the
term
there's this term enlightened centrist
that i sometimes use i want to introduce
a new term now
there is a sort of um oh what how could
i how could i describe it and
it's almost like uh
a calm
concocted de-escalation
that people hear this stuff and they say
that's alarmist
let's all calm down we're not going to
see this and we're not going to see that
and we're not going to see another
january 6th at this point
anybody who is called an alarmist simply
for saying
trump saying stuff publicly could lead
people to violence
should just point to january 6th and
they're not even hiding their desire for
a coup at this point in time
and there is a real a possibility and
these are people with a propensity to
violence we know that now there's no
question
look at the what is it 400 defendants in
the january 6th riot
related cases so i think there's a real
possibility
that not only do these trump rallies
inspire
more republicans to get out and vote in
2022
if trump keeps them going of course then
they will inspire democrats to get out
and vote
it also has the possibility of re
leading to to actual violence
and that's a really really scary thing
um just a couple other things that max
burns
uh writes here um
max burns writes indeed trump's return
to the political stage give democrats a
rare opportunity to set aside the
disagreements that come from governing
justice biden's honeymoon period is
ending
despite growing in patience among
progressives at the obstructionist
tactics displayed by democratic senators
kirsten cinema
of arizona and joe manchin of west
virginia trump's summer tour
will be a bracing reminder that things
could be far
worse i think that's probably the best
point max burns makes in this piece
which is you were starting to see more
and more
uh angry democrats and people on the
left saying biden should have already
done this
and biden should have already done that
and why he's doing this and where's the
public option
those are fair criticisms of joe biden
and i've participated in making many of
them
myself but i'm not losing sight of the
bigger picture here which is remember
what we had the last four years
the one thing that these trump rallies
coming back could do
um is remind us of
the craziness that was a trump
in comparison to biden hasn't yet done
everything he promised to
and it may sort of be uniting for the
left i think that that is plausible
but i do think that the trump rally
leads for uh
points to much more to gain for
republicans than for democrats
if you disagree if you agree with max
burns's take
that these trump rallies will just be
great for democrats going into 2022
i want to hear from you i just don't see
it here is a voicemail
left on our voicemail number that number
is 2192davidp
you can call anytime you want really
whenever you want
it is again about vaccines and
masks vaccines and masks let's take a
listen hello david hi
my name is ivan and and i want you to
know that i have like code black state
and thank god you were a mess and i'm a
big fan of yourself
so thank you bye that's great you know
what
last week we talked about how i got a
couple of angry emails from saying david
are you an anti-massacre you sound
disgusted with masks when you say
when the cdc guidelines changed i
stopped wearing my mask outside no
it's it's very strange how when the cdc
guidelines were
wear a mask here there there there there
uh i was doing it and i said
i'm following cdc guidelines and i'm a
team player
and then when the cdc guidelines changed
i still was saying
i'm following cdc guidelines and doing
what the cdc recommends
and a whole bunch of people got mad at
me and they said david no you should
still wear a mask everywhere
all the time i think it's great that
some people who are vaccinated
are still wearing masks and everybody
should assess their risk
just the other day even though masks are
no longer
required in just about any business
um i went to a grocery store and the
sign on the door said
uh we are still asking people to wear
masks
and i went inside and 99 of the shoppers
had masks
so i put my mask on and to be honest
part of it is because
often times at grocery stores like one
person will recognize me from the show
the last thing i want is to be the one
person in the grocery store not wearing
a mask i'm sure the masks will drop off
in grocery stores soon i know in some
parts of the country they already have
in the northeast not quite yet
and then i'll stop wearing the mask but
i think the great thing uh
about the the mask culture that now
exists is hopefully i've heard people
being attacked for wearing a mask in the
south but hopefully in most of the
country
if people determine that based on their
risk level or their particular health
situation or whatever they want to
continue wearing a mask
that's great they should do it and they
shouldn't be made fun of they shouldn't
be
attacked or whatever the case may be
that i think that that that is a great
thing
and as i've said before if during flu
season uh
we go back to hey you know what when you
go to a uh
grocery store and you're around a
hundred people um
during flu season maybe you wear a mask
maybe we do masks
during flu season indoors in crowded
places that doesn't seem crazy to me
uh but no i am no anti-massacre um i
don't
see any reason to wear one outdoors and
i've stopped doing it
i'm fully vaccinated i've stopped
wearing it indoors
in some places i was at a cafe over the
weekend nobody was wearing masks and i
wasn't either and that felt fine and
it's fine to wear masks like i continue
doing in grocery stores because that's
what everybody's doing
to each their own the masks are a good
thing particularly when we are
unvaccinated and we are slowly
going back to the way things were before
we have a great bonus show for you today
get instant access by becoming a member
at joinpackman.com i'll see you then
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read
or listen to an entire non-fiction book
in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman